Tại chính miếng ngày May tăng thằng mởi sắc nhận, Washington và Bắc Kinh đã đàn đồng một thỏa thuận nối này đang phán thương mại trong tần tới.
Đây là thích quả của cuộc đẹn đam giữa phó thu tưởng Trung Quốc Hà Lập Pham và bộ trường tại chính Miiscope Ben San,
bởi sức ham gia của đại diện thương mại Mi Jamies Sun Gear.
Hà bên anh giá của chơi đổi mang tính xây dựng và nhấn mạnh,
tâm quân trọng của bệ suy chi cân đối thoại cười mở.
Chúng khi đó, tổng thống May đôi năng trọng cổ sắc nhận vẫn sẽ gặp chủ tưởng Trung Quốc tập cận mình.
Sao hội nghi cấp cao dễ đặt hục các thình tại Chua thái mình dừng à cách ử hành quốc vàu củay tháng này.
Đồng thế này, giễn ra trong buộc anh,
căn thẳng trong quân này từng May Mi Trung, theo tháng trở lại khi Trung Quốc sét chặt kìm Sun ngành đất hiếm.
Con miếng thì giữa ác hưi cao đối giới hàng ngoài nhiệp khẩu tụi bắt kinh.
Giờ có sẽ trở rằng đến nối lại đăng phán là tính nhiều tích tưởng,
thì hiện mong muốn kìm xa bà đồng và chánh tất cả đồng tư cụm đến chuỗi cung tần cầu.